So, what else you have down for me? Go
ahead.
Okay, um
so I brought him like kind of the
Islamic dilemma, right? I brought him
first Quran verse 650 615 and 634,
right?
>> Yeah.
It says Allah's words cannot be
corrupted, right?
>> Yeah.
And he was like he said yeah, God's
words can't be changed but people can
change his words. It that doesn't mean
anything.
>> that was probably the stupidest comment
I've ever heard from someone claiming to
be a human being. In fact, because of
that comment
you just destroyed. I'm not saying you,
I'm saying that guy is stupid for saying
it. You just destroyed so many brain
cells I've become
less smart because of it. Notice the
idiot what he said. Notice how stupid it
is. Yeah, God's words can't be changed
but human beings can change his words.
That was like
>> [snorts]
>> pinch me, it can't be real. Wait, God's
words can't be changed but human beings
can change his words. Like change he
said like
changing his his scriptures, I guess.
>> Okay, but wait. That means God's words
can be changed.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, the light switch went on for you,
too?
Yeah, I know I got it but I'm like I
don't know like what can change.
>> Okay.
You ask him, "Mr. Stone Licker
Ibn Mu'taz, son of Mu'taz
the Quran, that's scripture, right?
Yeah.
Is that the words of Allah? Yeah.
Allah's words can't be changed, right?
Yeah. So, can you change the scriptures
called the Quran? No, because if you
change the scriptures you're changing
his words.
So, wait. You just said Allah's words
can't be changed but the scriptures
which are his words have been changed
which means Allah's words can be
changed.
But you just said they can't be changed.
But even though they have been changed
cuz the scriptures are his words and
they've been changed.
That's what we call a special kind of
stupid.
That's a stupid that you got to train
hard to be.
I mean, it's it's you go to school to be
that kind of that kind of stupid.
You get what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
Like the plane is coming and I'm like,
he's like, "Yeah, you can have your the
I can have the Quran. I can But I can
rewrite this verse. Doesn't mean it's
God's word."
>> No, you can't because when you rewrite
that verse, you have thousands of other
copies exposing your corruption. That's
the point. Because the Quran, I'm just
using his argument, has been written
down and spread all over the world. Even
if you corrupt that copy, you got 10,000
copies that expose that you corrupted
your copy and therefore your copy is not
valid. That's how we know it can't be
changed. So, guy's stupid. He's He's
parroting Jamal Badawi.
Mhm. Right? You understand the point?
Yeah, let's say I take a Quran and I
change it, right?
But how do you know I changed it?
Because you got 10,000 other Qurans that
all read the same contradicting my copy
proving that I must have changed it.
But if I didn't have enough Qurans to
know that I changed it, how did you know
it was changed? You see how stupid that
is?
Yeah. Think about it, okay.
This is my Quran.
And I changed it.
The only way you're going to know I
changed the Quran is if you have other
Qurans that are preserved
by which to judge my copy to see if it
agrees with them or it's been changed.
Right. So, how does he know the Bible's
been changed? That means he must have
accurate copies to know it's been
changed.
Right. Right. But if we have accurate
copies to know it's changed, that means
the Bible's preserved because we have
accurate copies that preserve it. Hello.
Yeah. You ask him next time, "Hey, what
color is the sky in your Jannah.
Okay? You see how stupid that was?
Yeah. That's a special kind of stupid,
my friend. Anyway, what else questions
you have? Go ahead, brother. Keep
asking.
>> Okay, I also brought up to him 5:68. I'm
like, it says that you have nothing to
stand upon unless you observe the Gospel
and Torah, right? Yeah. He's like, uh so
so I was like, why don't you follow the
Gospel and Torah? It says you have to
stand upon it.
And he was like, well, uh if if the
Gospel and Torah contradict each other,
he's like, I have to follow Quran. I'm
like, no, wouldn't you follow Why
wouldn't you follow the original one
that came first?
>> Yeah. And like I don't
>> so you don't make sense again because it
says, you must stand upon the Torah and
the Gospel and all the revelation that's
been sent to you from your Lord.
Where did the verse say what you said?
That if there's a contradiction between
the Torah and the Gospel, then I follow
the Quran. It says, no, follow all of
it. And again, because he's a special
kind of stupid,
uh what what it means is
yes, you you agree and confirm the Torah
is true.
But now that the Gospel has come, you
then see what the Gospel says about the
Torah
and which commands the Gospel says you
are still bound to follow and which
commands God has set you freed from.
Because that's what the Quran says the
Gospel does. Cuz in chapter 3 verse 50,
quoting Jesus, who's not the real Jesus,
but according to the Quran, it has Isa
saying, who's supposedly Jesus, "I
confirm the Torah that is between my
hands and I've come to make lawful some
of the things that were unlawful." And
in chapter 5 verse 46,
it says to the people of the Gospel,
"And in their footsteps, we sent Jesus,
the son of Mary, Isa, the son of Mary,
confirming
the Torah between his hands and we gave
him the Gospel and the Gospel confirms
the Torah between his hands."
Now, what's the point? That means that
not only does Jesus say, "Yeah, the
Torah is true. It is preserved. It's the
uncorrupt words of God. And my gospel
also confirms it's true. However,
because I've been sent with the gospel,
I now have the authority to tell you
these parts of the Torah you don't have
to follow. Not because they're corrupt.
It means those commands were for a
certain period of time. Now,
that I've come with my gospel, those
commands no longer need to be observed
cuz now you follow everything the gospel
and everything the gospel tells you
that you follow from the Torah. You
understand that?
Yeah. So, that's how you follow the
Torah and the gospel all the relations
sent to you from your Lord. By looking
at what the Torah said
and by looking at what the gospel says
about the Torah and what the gospel
tells you about the legislation of the
Torah. So, if the gospel says, "All that
legislation was true
and from God and hasn't been corrupted,
but it was only for a season and for a
specific people. Now, with the gospel of
Jesus, the gospel tells you which parts
of those legislation you follow and
which parts of those legislation you
don't need to follow anymore." And
that's what exactly the Quran says Jesus
did. Chapter 3, verse 50.
"I confirm the Torah between my hands
and I make lawful for you halal what was
prohibited haram."
Right.
Chapter 3, verse 50? Yeah, read it. Go
ahead, read it for me. And then all the
Muslim commentators say that Jesus made
lawful certain parts
of the Torah that had been forbidden.
Moses had forbade certain things in the
Torah that Jesus says, "Yes, the Torah's
true. It's the uncorrupt words of God,
but I have the authority to tell you
those parts of the Torah which forbid
you this, I now give you authority, you
can do them."
That's Chapter 3, verse 50. Read it.
Yeah. And I will confirm the Torah
revealed before me and legalize some of
what had been forbidden to you. There
you go.
Yeah.
So, hello.
Got anything else?
Yeah, um
Okay, I I I think this is dumb. I don't
know where he got this objection. So,
5:43
it's [snorts] like why do they come to
you when the
when they already have the Torah, right?
So, I was like So, I was like, "Yeah,
why would why would God tell them to go
to the Torah if the Torah is corrupt?"
>> Thank you.
And he was like, um
He's like, "No, but that was referring
back back back in time when the Torah
wasn't corrupt."
>> Say, uh
Uh it's your prophet is being told to
tell the Jews, "Why are they coming to
your prophet?" So, your prophet was
there back in time, too?
Yeah.
Okay, now this is why I said this guy's
got a special kind of stupid. Okay,
chapter 5:43 says to the Jews,
"Why are you coming to Muhammad?" It
says, "Why do they come to you,
Muhammad,
when they have the Torah, which contains
the commandment of God?
In it is guidance and light."
So,
Muhammad is being addressed and Muhammad
is being told to tell the Jews, "Hey
Jews, you don't come to me anymore. You
have your Torah, go to it." But
according to Einstein, it's not about
the Torah that was there in the past.
So, does that mean Muhammad was there in
the past, too? Cuz it's not about Jews
coming to Muhammad and he says, "Don't
come to me, go to your Torah." So, did
Muhammad have a time machine where he
and the Jews went back in time?
Yes, he did. See, I was telling you your
friend has got a special kind of stupid,
man. I mean, he had to go to school for
this.
He went to madrasa.
Madrasa to be this kind of this stupid.
Anyway, obviously you're not going to
talk to him this way. Me and you are
family and here we're talking freely.
You're going to try to love him enough
to bring him to Christ, but your friend
is got some mental issues. He He have a
genius
>> I I'm I'm I don't want to be like I
don't want to be like Evan jellyfish,
you know what I mean? But like No, no. I
don't I don't know like what what level
to go on. I'm a
>> going to tell you the level. Destroy his
arguments firmly and confidently without
insulting him.
Okay.
But if he starts insulting you and
blaspheming Jesus, then that's a
different story. But if he's not
insulting and he's not blaspheming
Jesus, say, "Come on, man.
Are you want me to believe that Muhammad
is telling them to go back in time
because it's not about Jews coming to
your prophet and he's telling them to
follow their Torah, what they had?
But you're telling me no, the original
Torah so what? Muhammad had a time
machine and went back in time with
them?"
Yeah, yeah, I know. He he's pretty
respectful, but yeah. Yeah, so be
respectful to
>> respectful. He's not Yeah, then be
respectful because you want to win him
to Jesus, win his heart, not insult him
and win a debate. I'm just playing
around with you because when a Muslim
calls who's respectful and doesn't
insult, I do nothing but respect that
person cuz I want them to fall in love
with Jesus.
But if he's a blasphemer who insults the
Lord, then I insult him and his mother
and the Shia who did mut'ah. Son of
mut'ah.
Abdul Abdul Abdul. Okay, what else you
have?
Okay,
um
he did bring up a verse.
He he said he didn't remember which
which one it was, but I think he's
referring to 2:79.
He's like he's like, "Yeah, it says like
woe to those who write the scriptures
and then change the words
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
Okay, now I can address that and refute
that if you want or you can watch the
videos, it's up to you. 2:79 is his
best?
I guess, yeah. I mean, if you want me to
I don't want to waste your
>> to 2:79. Open it up. Go ahead.
Okay, um
so woe to those who write the scripture
with their own hands and then say, "This
is from Allah in order to exchange it
for a small price. Woe to them for what
their hands have written and woe to them
for what they earn." Okay, number one,
why did he read the verse out of
context?
See, this is what he's been doing to the
Bible and he's doing it here with the
Quran.
So, woe to those. Who are the those that
it's referring to?
Uh I don't know. I don't know. The
context starts at 75. Now let's read
2:75 to 79 slowly and I'll stop you.
Okay. Okay. Uh so let me pull up cuz I
don't have a paper.
>> [snorts]
>> You don't have what?
I don't have a paper Quran. No, I know,
but you have online. So go to 2:275 to
79.
>> up. It's I need to scroll down. Sorry.
One sec. One sec. One sec.
Cuz it only shows like one verse at a
time. One verse at a time? No, but I
think what where are you what Quran
browser are you using?
Uh it's quran.com.
All right. Yeah, I hate that one. Let me
give you the one we have. We have a
Quran browser that we own that's part of
the Answering Islam website. Let's see
if that's going to work for you. This
one you can do multiple verses at a
time.
All right. Let me just get it for you.
Hold on. Let me see. One day at a time.
You just like for example if I say 2:75
to 79, you do 2:75-79.
Okay?
Okay. I'm going to send it to you right
now on the section. But then not only
that, you choose the translation so you
don't get all of them because it's going
to give you all of them.
Okay. All right. Hold on. Let me do
this.
All right. Right there. Here's the link.
Click on it and tell me if it works.
Okay. Go ahead and see if it opens.
Sorry. One sec. How do I go to chat?
Uh well, in your Skype, buddy. Skype. I
just sent it to you in Skype. Okay.
Okay. You see it? And then it says uh
chat. Do you get it?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
>> Okay. Now click on that link. See if it
opens up.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So 2 Yeah, choose the
translation. Choose pick one. Just
choose one. Put an X on one so you don't
get all of them. And then in the search
engine you put 2:75-79.
The two dots. 75-79. That's how you get
more than one verse. It's going to be
easier for you.
Search.
No connection is given. Okay. Um
Okay.
Sorry. Okay, sorry. Here it is. Here it
is.
Uh should I read it? Yeah, well, if you
want the genie to read it, you got a
genie there? Okay, okay, okay. Have ye
any hope that they will be true to you
when a party of them used to listen to
the word of Allah then used to change it
after they had understood it knowingly?
Okay, now notice, [snorts] before you
move on, a party, not all of them,
right? And this is at the time of
Muhammad, right?
Yeah. So, a party of of of the people of
the book, not all of them, only a
certain group at a certain time,
Muhammad's time. That means in Arabia,
right?
Yeah. They would twist the words of
Muhammad.
Okay, keep reading.
And when they fall in with those who
believe, they say, "We believe." But
when they go apart one with another,
they say, "Pray ye to them of that which
Allah has disclosed to you that they may
contend with you before your Lord
concerning that?" In other words, why
are you saying
this is referring, according to
commentaries, a group of Jews in Arabia.
They would lie to the Muslims and say,
"We believe." But then behind their
backs say, "We don't believe." And then
they're saying, "Hey, why are you
telling the Muslims what we believe in
our scriptures, man?" So, they use it
against us.
So, it's talking about a specific group,
not all Jews, a particular group at a
particular time, right?
Yeah. Okay, keep reading.
>> you Where Where do you Don't make me
bust my head. I'll bust my head against
the wall and I'm going to start singing
"Home by a". Okay, okay, I'll read Read
74. Read 75 again, dude. Read 75 again.
Okay.
Have ye any hope that they will be true
to you when a party of them used to
listen
>> of them, do you see? It's not that about
going to a disco or nightclub because
that's what your sinful mind is thinking
of.
Okay. Did it say party?
Yeah, party is like only some of them,
not all of them. Okay, so where did I
get it? I got it from the verse that you
were supposed to pay attention to. But,
you're thinking nightclubs, see party.
It's my party and I'll cry if I want to.
I'll cry if I want to. You'd cry, too,
if you only knew. It's not talking about
going to the nightclub and disco
dancing, dude.
Yeah. Are you laughing at me again?
No, no, no, no. Okay. So, is it all of
them or a party of them? Uh a party of
them. Okay. So, go ahead. Reread it
again.
Have ye any hope that they will be true
to you when a party of them used to
listen to the word of Allah then used to
change it after they have had understood
it knowingly.
You what?
And when they fall in with those who
believe, they say, "We believe."
But, when they go apart one with
another, they say, "Pray ye to them of
which
Allah hath disclosed to you that they
may contend
>> when they're with the believers, they
say they believe. Now, the believers in
the Quran would be who?
Uh the Muslims.
>> You got it. So, that means there's these
Jews saying to the Muslims, "Oh, we
believe in your deed." But, then when
they leave, they go, "Man,
you know we don't believe this garbage."
And then they're rebuking each other.
"Why are you telling the Muslims what we
have?" So, notice this must be at the
time of Muhammad, right?
Yes. And is it all of them or a group of
them?
A group of them. Okay, keep reading now.
Pray ye to them of which Allah Allah
have disclosed to you that they may
contend with you before your Lord
concerning it.
Have ye no sense Have ye then no sense?
Are they then unaware that Allah knoweth
that which they keep hidden and that
which they proclaim?
Among them are unlettered folk who know
the scripture not except from hearsay.
>> Now, before you move on, pay attention.
It says among this group, there are Jews
who are unlettered. Unlettered means
they don't know the Bible.
The word ummi means someone who hasn't
studied the Bible. And you know today
most Christians and Jews, though they
say they're Jews and Christians, they
haven't studied the Bible, right?
Yeah. So it says among them there is a
group who are unlettered, who don't know
the book except hearsay, right?
Yeah. Read 78 again.
Among them are unlettered folk who know
the scripture not except from hearsay.
They but guess.
>> Okay, now this is the same group now
mentioned in 79. This group does not
know the Bible. They only know it from
hearsay cuz they haven't studied the
book. They've only heard people talk
about it.
And that group did what in 79?
Therefore, woe be unto those who write
the scripture with their hands and then
they say this is from Allah.
>> So who is this group that writes the
scripture, a book that they claim is
from God when it's not in order to make
money? Uh a party of the people of the
book. And which party exactly they're
mentioned in 78?
>> Uh the the Jews. Yeah, but they're
mentioned in 78. Which group is this?
Oh, the the people who don't know the
scripture, the unlettered.
>> Okay, so if you read the context, it's
talking about one particular group of
Jews at the time of Muhammad who did not
know the Bible because they didn't read
it, who then wrote a book and claimed
it's revelation. How does this verse
prove that they corrupted the Bible?
It's talking about a book that's not the
Bible because they didn't read the
Bible, they didn't know the Bible, that
they were selling to make money, which
most likely means the Talmud because it
is a fact of history that the Jews did
produce a book called the Talmud.
You have the Babylonian Talmud and
Jerusalem Talmud which is full of
traditions and fables that they hold in
equal esteem to the Bible. So where did
you get that this passage says that all
the Bibles everywhere are corrupt? It's
speaking of a particular group of Jews
at the time of Muhammad and a particular
group of Jews who didn't know the Bible
cuz they didn't read it. They only heard
about it orally. They never had the
scroll. Then producing a book that they
sold to make money. But it's not all
Jews and it's not at all times. And what
do you do with the Christians who also
had copies of the Bible that they would
not corrupt or agree with the Jews to
corrupt?
Um, wait. Sorry. Can you repeat that
question? Sorry. I'll bust my head
again.
Which part you didn't hear?
Uh, no. What did you say about the
Christians at the time?
>> Okay. So, weren't there Christians all
over the world at the time Muhammad who
had the Old Testament as well?
Yes. So, are you telling me that the
Christians agreed with the Jews to
corrupt the Old Testament? The same way
that these particular group of Jews were
corrupting
their sources?
No. So, even if one group corrupted the
Bible, let's say it's different. One
group at one location. You have now
millions of Jews and Christians all over
the world
with copies of the Bible spread all over
the world. Are you telling me they all
gathered together and say, "Hey, you
guys over there with Muhammad. We're
going to corrupt our Old Testament too
to agree with your corruption."
Yeah, no. You see why I say your friend
has a special kind of stupid?
Uh-huh.
But respect them and love him and pray
that God saves him cuz we want them to
get saved. We don't want to win
arguments. We want to get them saved by
the power of the Spirit using us so they
can follow up with Jesus, escape God's
wrath, and enjoy Jesus our Lord forever.
That's your goal. It's not about winning
an argument. But if he's a jerk and if
he's a blasphemer who insults Jesus,
blasphemes Jesus, mocks the Bible, then
you muzzle him because he's a dog and a
swine according to Matthew 7:6.